-Our next guest is an author
and staff writer
at "The Atlantic."
His new book,
"Romney: A Reckoning,"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
McKay Coppins, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show.
-Thanks for having me.
-So, this is
a very impressive book
because of the amount of access
you were granted by Mitt Romney.
He gave you journals,
he gave you texts,
he gave you access
to e-mails he wrote.
Are you surprised
at how much he gave you?
-I was surprised when
he agreed to do it at all.
-Yeah.
-Because, you know, Mitt Romney,
was known for most
of his political career
as, like, this very cautious,
you know, restrained,
calculated politician
who was stuck
to his talking points.
And when I approached him
about doing this book,
I told him,
"I only want to do this
if you're ready
to be fully candid."
And I knew he was on board
when like a couple weeks
into it,
he sent me a text.
I was actually at church.
I got a text from him.
He says,
"Hey. Check your e-mail.
I sent you something
that might be interesting."
And it was just hundreds
of pages of his journals.
And I was like, "Oh, wow.
Alright.
We're gonna do this for real."
-He already was --
He sort of started
as an outsider in the Senate.
You know, he had been vocally
opposed to Donald Trump,
especially on character.
And then he joins the Senate,
where the GOP caucus
is obviously very full-throated
in their defense
of Donald Trump.
Yet, I imagine he has to be
even more on the outside
now that this book has come out.
Have you spoken to him
since it's been released?
-Yeah, well, a few weeks ago,
like, the first excerpts
from the book came out,
and, you know, he says
some very damning things
about a lot of his colleagues
in the Senate.
And I checked in with his staff.
I was like,
"How's everything going?"
They were like, "He's skipping
the caucus lunches
for a little while.
-Yeah.
-He's doing okay."
I mean, he knew that
this was gonna make for,
like, a weird few weeks
or months at work.
But it's to his credit
that he went along with it.
-Well, you know,
it's called "A Reckoning,"
and that's a very apt title
for this book.
And even you talk about how he
was very careful with his words.
It does feel like this moment
has broken him to some degree
and it's broken his spirit.
And he is using this
as a warning to all of us.
-I think that's why he
ultimately decided to do this.
I approached him just
a few weeks after January 6th,
and I still remember
our first meeting
was in his, like,
little Senate office.
The barbed-wire fence
was still around the Capitol.
And he --
Like, something snapped in him
almost after January 6th
because it demonstrated
just how far his party
had kind of descended into what
he considers authoritarianism.
He told me in one
of our first meetings,
you know, "A very large portion
of my party
really doesn't believe
in the Constitution."
And I think that was
eye-opening for him.
And he decided that it was time
to sort of tell the stories
of what he had seen
inside these caucus rooms,
inside Republican politics
over the last 30 years
so that Americans would know,
you know,
just what we're up against,
what's happening and what's
happening to his party.
-There's a very real, obviously,
threat he's addressing.
There's also, you know,
very funny ways
he describes his colleagues.
Well, not that funny.
Ted Cruz. "Scary,
demagogue, frightening."
Mitch McConnell told Romney,
"You're lucky you can say
the things we all think."
That is one of
Romney's messages,
is he isn't actually
the only one who thinks this.
He's the only one
who says it out loud.
J.D. Vance. "I don't know
that I can disrespect
someone more than J.D. Vance.
How do you sit
next to him at lunch?"
-And now he's stuck
sitting next to him at lunch.
-Yeah.
-I mean, you know, look.
Like, when these quotes
started to come out,
people were like, "Oh,
Mitt Romney is being petty,"
or he's, you know,
consumed with these
old resentments or whatever.
But, like, I think it's really
he's kind of heartbroken.
Like, he believed in this party.
He believed in what he thought
were the core tenets
of the Republican Party.
And instead
what it turns out is,
like, all these guys
that he once respected
just lined up behind
this, like, manifestly crazy
person in Donald Trump.
And now he, you know --
And they're all telling him
in private,
"We agree with you, Mitt, but
we can't say the same things
because we have to
win re-election."
And so I think that, you know,
he's well within his rights
to say a few of these quotes
that we have in the book.
-And it's also interesting
because this is --
You know, you sort of have
documentary evidence.
This is not something
that he's doing now.
These are things that
he has written in journals.
These are things --
These are thoughts he's had...
-Going back a decade or longer.
Yeah.
-Donald Trump --
it won't surprise anybody --
was not a fan of the book.
But I should note this is --
I want to just read
the first couple lines
because this is a biography.
-Correct.
-You wrote this book.
-That's right.
-"Mitt Romney, a total loser
that only a mother could love,
just wrote a book
which is much like him --
boring, horrible,
and totally predictable."
So...Donald Trump thinks
that Mitt Romney wrote a book.
-He did. [ Laughs ]
He seems slightly confused
between biography and memoir.
-Yeah.
-In his defense,
he probably has never read
one of either, so...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I think that's accurate.
-I will say --
I will say I texted it --
When I saw that,
I texted that to Mitt.
And his response --
his response was,
"Ha ha ha.
He's such a whack job."
That's right.
-It's so funny because, like,
Trump might think he wrote it
because his face
is on the cover,
but if that's true,
Trump wrote 100 books this year.
Like, Donald Trump's on
the cover of every other book.
You also -- It does seem like --
Certainly as excerpts
coming out,
a lot of the press
is talking about the moment
we're living in now,
but in 2012,
Romney obviously was the GOP
nominee running against Obama.
And you discovered --
Not a thing you knew.
Not a thing people are paying
that much attention to now.
That, in 2012,
six weeks before the election,
he almost dropped out.
-Yeah. This is one of
the most fascinating things
I found in his journals.
Like, you know, it was after
that hot-mic moment came out.
Remember when he talked
about the 47% of Americans
who would never vote for him
and he kind of disparaged them?
It was in a closed-door
fundraiser.
So, that tape came out,
and, you know, at the time,
publicly,
he tried to defend himself
and say the comments
are being taken out of context
or whatever.
In his journals, he was
anguished over this coming out
to the point where people
in his circle thought he was,
like, clinically depressed.
He couldn't sleep.
he couldn't eat.
He would every night
go into his journals
and write like, "I'm so stupid.
I can't believe I did this."
Really beating himself up.
And he writes about
in his journals
one night, six weeks
before the election,
he called the chief strategist
of his campaign
and said,
"I think I need to drop out.
You should let Chris Christie
or somebody take take the job."
That's kind of
how depressed he was.
I think it also speaks to, like,
there's something about
Mitt Romney where he, like,
desperately hates
letting people down.
And he felt like with that gaffe
that was kind of
derailing his campaign,
he had let down his, you know,
the people who supported him,
the people
who had donated to him.
You know, he eventually
pulled himself back up,
and he lost the election,
but, you know, that moment,
I thought, was really revealing.
-It must be a weird time for him
because he is still
a conservative.
He has conservative principles.
He stands for a lot
of conservative ideals,
and yet his party
has, you know, ostracized him.
There are times where the left,
you know, eats it up
when he says negative things
about his colleagues,
but ultimately, he's no hero
of the left, either.
One thing that I did find
endearing on a human level
is he has connected
with President Biden
on just the idea
of what it's like to age.
-Yes, he has struck up
this friendship with Joe Biden
the last couple of years
because he found that, like,
they actually get along,
you know, on some things
even though
they disagree on politics.
And they spend
a lot of their time
commiserating about
the indignities of getting old
as two old guys are wont to do.
But there's this one story
about, apparently,
during one of these calls,
he told Joe Biden,
"You know, I've been watching
some of your public events
and you shuffle when you walk
and it makes you look old.
And one of the tricks
that I've learned
is take longer strides.
It'll make you look youthful
and energetic."
And so, apparently,
a few weeks later,
Joe Biden called him back
and said,
"Mitt, I took your advice
and it worked."
[ Laughter ]
He said, "I had given this --
I gave a speech,
and I finished,
and I was leaving the stage,
and I made a point
to take big, long steps.
And I got off,
and the first lady was there,
and she said,
'What's gotten into you?!'"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, he should write a book,
like, "How to Walk
Impressively."
Yeah, exactly.
Congratulations on this.
Thanks so much
for being here tonight.
I really enjoy talking to you.
McKay Coppins, everybody.
"Romney: A Reckoning"
is out now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."